hey this is Kim from Khan Academy I am
the history fellow here and I am here
with Emily hi I'm the biology fellow so
Emily and I are here talking about
Darwinism and I'm interested in
Darwinism because in the late 19th
century I usually call the Gilded Age
there is a very prominent interpretation
of Darwinism that is called social
Darwinism and social Darwinism wasn't so
much an actual form of biology as it was
kind of a misinterpretation of how
natural selection and the theory of
evolution worked that was used to
justify or explain a lot of the social
inequalities of this time period and the
way people often thought about it was
that white anglo-saxon people so
Europeans Northern Europeans were kind
of the most evolved and this is our
timeline of evolution from least evolved
to most evolved and people like
african-americans or Asians or Native
Americans or even Eastern Europeans were
less evolved that they were on a scale
of evolution where they hadn't come as
far as anglo-saxons
so Emily you're a biologist and I would
love to get your take on how it is that
natural selection actually works and how
this doesn't quite describe what was
really going on yeah definitely on so
maybe I can speak first to that specific
graph that you've drawn on and I think
that this is actually a common point of
confusion when it comes to evolution
that there's not really such a thing as
more or less evolved in evolution okay
so this is this gradient really doesn't
exist no I mean there's on there's sort
of the I think that people sometimes see
the pictures of like the eep standing
up and turning into a person and they
think oh this is sort of a linear path
from one thing to another but what you
really get is different types of
organisms evolving from a shared
ancestor and branching off so alright so
nobody who's alive on earth today has
been evolving for more or less time
since their last common ancestor than
anybody else
so would you I'm gonna draw what I think
is how you're explaining this and please
correct me as I go along but say this is
my common ancestor and then would there
possibly be branches like this yeah
that's a great way to draw it and I mean
you know certainly humans are all
extremely closely related to each other
but like we could even say this for us
versus a dog a bacteria like pretty much
anything all life on Earth shares a
common ancestor and so that bacteria is
just as well as evolved as you are
actually in the sense of absolute time
since since those two split apart right
so like from the moment that life first
appeared on earth there has been so much
time and all of us have been evolving
from that point so even whether you're a
piece of bacterial piece a good word of
a bacterium there you go Nestle
bacterium I I took biology once um or
you are Albert Einstein you have been
evolving for precisely the same amount
of time yep awesome
okay wow I'm really relieved to find
that I could deserve it as well good you
did a great job beautiful um so okay so
you've done this this distinction
between evolving from a common ancestor
so how is it that the actual theory of
natural selection works yeah that's a
great question so natural selection
often people talk about it as sort of
having three key ingredients and to see
how it works on let's imagine that we're
just looking at a population of beetles
so picture picture your beetles to start
with on and what what would we need to
have
in order for these beetles as a group to
evolve by natural selection so one thing
that we would need is we would need some
variation among the beetles so if you
have identical beetles you're not going
to have any that are better at surviving
or reproducing than any others which is
kind of a key ingredient for what we're
going to talk about okay so I've got two
different beetles here they're slightly
different from each other
awesome and you've made them different
colors which is perfect so we have
variation and in the next ingredient
that we're going to need so we're going
to need that variation to be heritable
so we're going to say that those beetles
one of them is green and one of them is
blue and that's because of something in
their DNA so they have differences in
their DNA that create the variation in
colors okay so all right so when you say
heritable you mean that this is
something that their descendants could
inherit exactly that is that is exactly
it so the final ingredient is that the
difference is these heritable
differences need to affect how good the
beetles are at leaving offspring in the
next generation okay so for example
let's let's say we would probably have
more than two beetles in our actual
population but let's say this population
has just moved into a new area that is
very blue colored okay so blue rocks
blue flowers whatever and there's also a
bunch of birds in that environment that
really like to eat beetles and I'm
guessing that if they have blue beetles
and green beetles that one of those is
going to show up a lot better against
the blue environment than the other so
probably a lot of our green beetles are
going to get picked off by birds and
they're not going to be able to leave
offspring because gosh they kind of got
at so when you look at the next
generation of beetles if we know that
the colors get passed on we're going to
probably see a bigger group of that a
bigger proportion of that group being
made up of Blue Beetle
and less being made up of green and that
is an example of natural selection and
action where you can see that that
organisms that survive and specifically
reproduce better in a certain
environment are going to increase in
frequency in a population so you're
going to get more and more of these blue
guys less and less of the green guys is
there a word you would use to describe
this sort of this adaptation is that the
natural selection part as from variation
and heritable like the natural selection
is just like a good situation yeah I
mean natural natural selection is really
the just the the differential survival
and reproduction and as you you
mentioned a great word there which is
adaptation on so adaptation is is the
word that biologists often give to the
the process of a population getting
better and better suited to its
environment so you would say that the
population was adapting to being in a
blue space as it gradually started to
have more and more blue beetles across
generations so what I find really
interesting about this is that it's
entirely by chance right more or less
you've got a genetic mutation and then
that mutation happens to suit the
environment that you're in which allows
you to thrive and your jeans and your
adaptations to be passed on over time
yes and I mean the the variation would
have occurred randomly to start with
like you say it would have been a
mutation it didn't happen because the
Beatles went to a blue place and said
gosh I should be blue that'd be awesome
that was not what happened that it was
already there and it just happened to be
successful in that environment if they'd
gone to a green place well guess what
you would have gotten exactly the
opposite effect suddenly the green guys
would have been more successful more
able to leave offspring and you would
have seen green be increasing or
quote-unquote favored by natural
selection